Clark County School District police
investigating whether there was an
attempt to cover up what they call
failings at an elementary school police
say it began after a special ed teacher
was accused of child abuse authorities
say that's when an effort began to
create paperwork to dismiss that teacher
Joshua peguero digs deeper into this
case he joins us from The Newsroom now
with more Joshua now Catherine
Fitzgerald was a teacher at gerheim
elementary school for four years last
year she was put on leave and
investigated by police police say they
did not find anything criminal but did
find suspicious activity done by
administrators
Fitzgerald who declined speaking on
camera was accused of abusing the nephew
of Victoria K Bush the guardian of a
seven-year-old with autism Cable says
she had a hard time believing the
allegations she has been an amazing
blessing in our life and in our child's
life and
we don't know where we would be without
her and aide accused Fitzgerald of
tackling Kate Bush's nephew last year
police reviewed this surveillance video
we showed the video to Kate Bush it was
exactly what we thought we knew it our
gut knew it she scooped him right up and
and it was just exactly what he needed
the investigation into Fitzgerald
started back in October for incidents
that happened weeks prior authorities
say when a teacher uses force on a
special needs child they have 24 hours
to fill out an adverse restraint form
per CCSD policy reports indicate that
was never done in this instance and 1A
told police she thinks there needs to be
more training officers interviewed the
special ed facilitator at gerheim
Sterling Olson Olson says she was
directed to fill out the restraint forms
by associate superintendent Scarlett
Perryman she adds that Perryman told her
to backdate those forms during the
course of the investigation more than 30
such forms were found the investigating
officer even stating there appears to be
an attempted cover-up with failings from
the teaching assistant to the special ed
facilitator and principal he ended the
report by labeling the documentation
concerning
now Fitzgerald was suspended by CCSD but
she has appealed that CCSD confirms to
us that the principal at gurham at the
time Ryan Lewis was assigned to other
duties reporting live in The Newsroom
Joshua figuero eight news now